[Music]
[Applause]
in the red light shine
streets are Hey
where the devil
who knows what
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
trying to save
[Music]
the captain said
without his boy some things are getting
better
[Music]
the things a little
it's a situation much like a curse
[Music]
[Applause]
sidewalk
store
[Music]
[Applause]
the captain of the shore
there's a garden
[Music]
[Applause]
on his tail
[Music]
set the hell renew the me about a woman
delicious
in a matter of days
[Music]
[Applause]
we're down on me
[Music]
I can tell you this you got to be free
[Applause]
[Music]
action
when push comes to shove
[Music]
here's what you believe
the captain amazed Thank You student
[Music]
Rhys would be pleased
[Applause]
[Music]
so my friend dams
you take your leave
[Music]
[Applause]
see
[Music]
and the church bell tolls
[Applause]
[Music]
Harvey
[Applause]
[Music]
every night
my dreams I see you I feel you that is
how I know you cross the distance and
spaces between
[Music]
small you
my heart and my heart
[Music]
let go
when car
[Music]
I loved you one true time
where
[Music]
part two
people from the african-american
community working in this country there
was almost in terms of total almost 160
million people that african-american
senator record out of that 160
african-american unemployment and
employment was the best they were the
best numbers that we've ever had that
goes for many others also
asian-americans you know that we sent
records with Asian Americans and
Hispanic Americans and then we had the
plague flow in China and that we're
doing it again you're gonna see some
incredible numbers sorting in june/july
you're gonna see some incredible numbers
because it's coming back and it's coming
back fast I spoke to CDC today about
churches and again our churches opened
we got to get our country open these
governors have to start doing what
they're supposed to be doing together we
passed also criminal justice reform
which is a big deal and that's something
that could not be passed without us and
I will tell you I have a very good
friend of mine that where'd you come in
from Cleveland what to be here I'm very
impressed with you your buddy is here
other than that my president but we did
we didn't ask we did pass criminal
justice or before one of my advisors
prison reform a lot of things that
nobody else put it then and nobody else
could have done and the Democrats I
don't even know if they tried but if
they did they couldn't get it done so we
got it done
thank you very much we delivered record
funding for HBCUs and made the funding
permanent so every year I would have
people come from the black colleges
small large all sizes and they would
come in colleges and universities and
then ask me for money after the third
Garrison and I said what's going on over
here what's happening why do you keep
coming every year they had they needed
it every single year
what man said to me we feel like beggars
we keep coming to the White House every
year I said why don't we make it
permanent to make it won't term and I
got it approved so now you're
historically black colleges and
universities small and large great
schools they have long term funding that
are not the only thing as I said some of
them became friends of mine the leaders
of these colleges I said I won't be
seeing you anymore
so and they didn't mind that actually
because now they can have a life of
making their school's great and making
their college is great but we did that
and I think most people don't even know
about that but every year three years I
got to see the same people and would
come in and every 36 38 40 of the Oval
Office will take a picture that's a
beauty how come you keep coming back and
they said because it's a year-to-year
deal I said that's unbelievable for many
years year to year so they have to come
in and beg you said we feel like beggars
I've said that could happen anymore we
got it done perfectly
good right well anybody write about it
no that's okay I think the people know
as long as the people know staff we got
to get the word out my pastor has to get
the word out and how do you as to see
him we created nearly 9,000 opportunity
zones including 94 right here in Detroit
and we're opening and we're rebuilding
and we're doing a job and you can see
the numbers start coming in the
projections came in yesterday Larry
Kudlow has now made the projections are
looking really good so we built the
greatest economy in the world greatest
economy in the history of the world
better than China by a lot China had the
worst year they had in 67 years before
the before the virus came in and with
that they would do it look I want
everybody to do well but we would do it
better than anybody and it wasn't even
close there wasn't anybody even close to
us and now I'm going to do it again we
had to shut it off they came in and we
did the right thing we would have lost
millions of lives we did the right thing
but now we're opening up again I'm going
to open our churches again I think CDC
has had put something out very soon
spoke to them to that I think they're
going to put something out very soon
we've got to open our churches people
want to go and the scene today when
people are trying to break into a church
to go into the church not to break in
and steal something the break did they
want to be in that church I said you
better put it out and they're doing it
and they're going to be issuing
something today or tomorrow or churches
I'm going to get our churches open so
with that I just like to thank everybody
for being here your friends your great
people and supporters forget the word
supporter I don't care I want to take
care of everybody and a man who's done
an incredible job for me has been Carson
met please say a few words
president and thank you all for being
here today and for welcoming us here and
for your tremendous resilience that
we've seen in this area it said that
crisis reveals character and the koban
19 national emergency has revealed the
indomitable spirit of people of michigan
and the men and women of the auto bill
industry as the secretary of HUD in
conjunction with the president have
directed our department to do everything
within our power to help the American
workers and their families remain in
their homes prevent this location and
receive the critical services from the
federal government that includes
allocating more than twelve billion
dollars under the cares Act which is the
cares Act is the single biggest economic
relief package in American history and
as a member of the White House rotavirus
task force have also had the privilege
of working with some of our leaders not
only to respond to the coveted 19 but to
set America back on a path of reopening
and as we're seeing here at 4:00 today
the path to putting Americans back in
business is already well underway
we appreciate those efforts as a
president said before this virus came
along we were humming along making
really records in terms of
african-american Hispanic American Asian
American unemployment women is the best
employment numbers in 71 years this is
really in a historic period and what we
need to recognize is that the economic
infrastructure that created that
economic Renaissance is still there we
have to make sure that it's not
destroyed and the way to do that
obviously is to get people back to work
again that's why the emphasis is on that
while at the same time maintaining of
strong emphasis on making sure that our
patient other people are healthy and I
think it's become part of the American
DNA now we've learned about sanitizing
everything including our hands being
careful about the kinds of things that
we touch that are being touched by
multiple people social distancing
wearing mats when we can't social
distance you'll notice that at this
table we are social distancing and now
President Trump and this administration
have organized the largest national
mobilization since World War two
providing PP
providing ventilators you know the troit
which was once the most prosperous city
in the nation because of its industrial
infrastructure now is showing what it
can do and other portions of Michigan
what it can do in the manufacturing
arena real Superstars and we've also
been renewing and expanding our focus on
helping the communities that have been
hit the hardest three and a half weeks
ago the president asked us in the
opportunity and revitalization committee
to focus on those individuals or
underserved who have been hit the
hardest in our economy and we're looking
at it we're looking at their physical
health we're also looking at their
economic health and we're looking at the
things that really caused them to have
more problems than the general
population yes there may be more
hypertension there may be more diabetes
there may be more obesity and asthma but
we also have better self why are there
more of those things and we have to
address those issues and and that's why
all the different agencies and the
government have combined to put together
the kind of program that will address
these things on a sustainable basis and
we need to just remember that we have
the bridge the gap because we have a
very
strong economy which is the bridge to
get until we get beyond this virus as
the president mentioned there's
tremendous progress being made in terms
of their pew digs in terms of vaccines
and if there is a second wave and it's
not clear whether there will be but if
there is believe me we're going to be
ready for it but we're also going to be
ready to recapture the spirit that
created the most powerful and dynamic
economy the world has ever known it is
just around the corner and I believe
that we're going to make it and you know
we've learned that in times of Plenty
the incredible blessings of the Lord are
with us and when times are not so good
we also know that this too will pass we
will learn from this and we will be
stronger than ever
thank you very much better appreciate it
a young man who has got a tremendous
future he's going to be a senator
hopefully soon he's representing a state
that has already fallen in love with him
I saw him a few years ago I watched him
on television I said who was that guy
and I found out his name was John James
and they said he's going to be fantastic
and he ran a great race and now he's
running a race that's people he loves
the people he wants to help the people
he's running for the United States
Senate everybody knows that in this wage
steak we should get John would you say a
few words please
and mr. Kosan thank you for coming you
I'm tremendously honored to have the
opportunity to speak on behalf of the
state and communities to where of
extraordinary needs to the president of
United States of America we're one of
the hardest hit States for colanow
devastation has struck central Michigan
where more than 10,000 been evacuated
our hearts and minds and prayers of
adventure small businesses continue need
support our food banks have capacity
needs as shelters need funds which is
why we've repurposed our campaign funds
in large part giving back nickel for
every dollar we raise to help feed the
hungry to help clothe make to help heal
the city take of our veterans recently
we have been 200 thousand to to a
medical facility in Detroit in-person
testing Detroiters in the toughest hit
area in the country distributing
hundreds of thousands meals I'm not
gonna steal her thunder she's doing
great work and our logistics company
automotive company headquartered in
Detroit we were able to do able to help
her there we actually process and ship
material made in this plant sir and we
sell them abroad we keep American jobs
here by making people buy our American
goods we ship American goods not
American jobs so I've said for a long
time sir you don't need to go to
Venezuela to see the effects of
socialism evil right doc right down the
highway in Detroit and I recently
attended not been to Michigan Chronicle
about how 40% of Michigan koba's desks
were african-americans and when you look
at the
for synthesis made up he gets to
secretary Carson dr. Carson's coming
about me having a more sustainable path
mr. president I believe and agree with
you that the 21st century prosperity
agenda that focuses on economic security
health and wellness and having leaders
with personal estate and addresses the
generational poverty among blacks in
Michigan and around the country is
something that you've agreed with and
set your mind to because as we all know
both natural and man-made disasters
always have a way of unmasking
generations of disinvestment and
exploitation of African Americans I
think that a great start is something
that you've already done mr. president
this is the Motor City this is the
arsenal democracy and when called upon
Michigan Detroiters stood up we're
making ventilators right past this pipe
and drape because you call the president
called the nation called and Michigan
stood up I believe that you know us for
cars and trucks and I think in the
future you can know us for planes and
rockets mr. president you're moving jobs
back from overseas you're moving ship
manufacturers in Arizona you're bringing
pharmaceutical manufacturers in Virginia
I think we have an opportunity to bring
aerospace and rockets back to Michigan
now you sign the order mr. president
executive order 13224 this crisis came
assessing and strengthening the
manufacturing and defense industrial
base and supply chains ovc of the united
states you know inside of this president
you sign that in july 2017
I don't think you've been present at
that time for what eight months
at that point and you are already
thinking about our supply chain the
sustainability and repatriation of jobs
our economic strength I want to thank
you for that for that mr. president I
think we can build on that by expanding
the national emergency declaration to
encompass the economic threat of our
national security our economical I think
that Michigan once again can stand up
when called by its president and looking
at additional opportunities for f-35
then looking at a launched initiatives
with lost little works worth for a space
in polar orbit but also take comments
missions sir we have the workforce here
but we need data we need training and we
need jobs in order to emerge from this
with a more sustainable path that dr.
Carson laid out and like you have been
laying out the better part that's four
years mr. president thanks major or
better and I trust the people state of
Michigan United States America so I'm
looking forward to working with you and
anybody else who wants to protect
American jobs to protect America so
thank you for being well thank you John
you're doing a fantastic job of getting
also some reports flowing reports and if
you do come to Washington you have my
ear and your gentleman that you're
opposing tell you nobody even knows who
we is nobody knows who he is
never heard of him and he's a senator so
go out and do the job finish the job and
be gonna bring a lot of wealth back to
this state because it deserves it okay
thank you very much making this really
great job I want to just call out j-rod
Smith he's been here for with me like
from the beginning we never call him out
we never he works so hard I said I want
to call him out he doesn't want to be I
don't know he's not a shy man but he's a
very capable man and you've been right
from the beginning and I want to thank
you you like to say something you can he
never wants to bother but this is one
tough smart cookie go ahead general well
say first of all mr. president thank you
so much for your leadership a lot of the
challenges that are in the
african-american community or historic
nation of course the Kovach pandemic
shine a bright light on some of those
historic disparities rather is access to
capital or this access to health care or
you know the environments that people
grow up in what we've established
through the White House opportunity
revitalization council that you set up
two years ago set off to take upon that
challenge to change it when you ran and
wanted to make the country great it was
making the land of opportunity again
opportunity for all Americans rather the
african-american in Detroit or you're
from Appalachia you know this panic
American living in San Antonio
everyone should be about get a chance to
be a part of the American dream and
since we had a debt infrastructure in
place the White House revitalization
Council they made it easy for us to
renew that focus and help with the
recovery of underserved communities and
through that council we're developing
even more muscles with partners partners
here at this table to help us really
change the way we've ever done things
for these vulnerable populations and I
believe that through your leadership
we're going to arise out of the ashes of
this like a phoenix stronger than ever
and so thank you so much and we look
forward to continuing to work with you I
just want to thank you for being an
incredible talent in the White House and
a friend of Jared and a friend of the
administration done a fantastic job
thank you very much appreciate it
representative Karen Whitsett highly
respected person loved in the Detroit
area she only wanted one thing she wants
to take care of people she doesn't care
if they're Republicans Democrats
let's and I saw her story on television
and said incredible story but she's an
incredible woman and I don't care if
she's a Democrat or a Republican I just
think it's very important that we keep
her here and healthy and she will take
care of whoever she has to take care of
and it's an honor to see you and I
really appreciate you like just a couple
of Thank You mr. president is just an
honor and a pleasure to be here and that
you want to take to me and this
wonderful conversation I am truly
honored and humbled to be before you
right now to be able to discuss some of
the issue that that have transpired in
my community I think dr. Carson for
pointing out some of the most troubling
things that we do have going on in the
community but you have started working
on these things long before now and I do
mr. president give you a lot of credit
for that and I thank you for it
we we as a community have been
struggling and as you know our poverty
level is extremely high in the area and
everyone is not meant to go to college
so one of the things I would like to
point out is that training is a
necessity and indeed as John has
mentioned that is something that is
imperative for the community we have
proper training then we can change our
printers into homeowners we can change
the dynamic of my community that I have
been in since 1969 and my husband and I
we grew up on the same Street we've been
there since I guess in 1969 and my
in-law still live a few doors
for me and I know how great are queuing
with them still it's imperative that I I
know that our community can change I
know it can go back to I know how
wonderful it was before and I nobody
can't grow back into being if we can
turn renters into homeowners and we can
put the dollars back into the community
and we can change the lives of single
mothers that are struggling to make ends
meet which we have been doing with you
know food distribution but food
distribution is not the end-all we don't
want to stay where people are asking for
things constantly we want people to be
able to stand on their own two feet and
be resilient within their own community
and take pride in that as well as being
able to you know as you address the box
of historical black colleges I would
love to see a historical black college
in the city of Detroit I think that
would be amazing and I think you're just
the president to be able to make that
happen it's an interesting idea actually
I think that you can they've got a lot
of money now funding for home repairs
for our seniors our seniors are really
struggling and everyone does not have
children everyone does not have a spouse
and they don't have family they can
count on so our seniors are suffering
because they do not have money for
repairs for their roof
for ramps and for their porches and
there's something extremely important to
them and to be able to maintain as you
know to be able to maintain seniors in
their homes is life-changing I mean we
have programs that assist but we don't
have programs that address directly
address this within a community to be
able to empower seniors to stay in their
homes and I think we can make a whole
world of difference by doing that and
you've considered everything else that I
want to talk about but I think your idea
about historically black colleges
universities coming here one real good
one I think it's a great idea with all
you said that really I remember
everything you said word for word but
you know what that was an idea I had
nerd up I don't know if anyone's ever
thought of that but John you were still
working on that this is not a good idea
that might have been a filler for you it
might have been just a filler but it
wasn't a filler up John James worked on
it a giant works on it up at yet
happened oh my god to happen I mean
James is amazing that people working
really great together you're looking
forward to continue working with you and
the White House be able to continue
Interbrand has been awesome to work with
say adios I will actually I'm incorrect
oh he's in the car can we bring them in
please
is he alright Scotty doesn't qualify
would you do me a favor could you have
somebody go out and find them thank you
starlet of committee he only saved your
life right not feeling too well one
night and she said would you do me a
favor go down to the store and get a
particular thing and that was a big that
was a big evening though he does not
deserve to be sitting in a car let's
bring him in okay
I took a note from you and so I actually
filed a lawsuit to the governor today as
well you would like to know that that
sounds very good you got my note
right yes thank you very much great job
Scott could you say a few words please
outstanding guy Thank You mr. president
and I'm so happy to be here with you sir
thank you for your leadership really
your heart for America and the heartbeat
of America and thank you all for being
here
servant leaders at this table this
afternoon and some honor to sit with you
you know Detroit as I wrote down and you
know secretary Carson having roots he I
wrote down you know Detroit is the
epitome of hard work and ingenuity and
innovativeness and I think that same
spirit and resolve is still here in
Detroit and in this up I'm grateful to
be here in Toronto about the White House
opportunity and revitalization Council
and how the spirit of that council is
economic development and also community
development and social impact to see
those inside of the communities in which
we serve to thrive and to benefit and
for long-term sustainability
now this want to encourage everyone here
that our vision and our spirit is still
the same we are not unaware we are not
you know oblivious to the severity of
the copán but our mission remains our
face is set like flint you know we are
steadfast and we're not going to be
moved by this the president has
refocused and repurposed the council
with a broader vision and that's why
we're here today to hear from you to
share with you to create partnerships as
weekend's iran talks about in coalitions
but mr. president we are in the right
place at the right time
and I made a Detroit can be a shining
example through the recovery during the
Coleman and after the coma and that
America could see you know Americans
want to go to work we are working people
and small-business drives America they
were in a great place today you know and
to not just to take the tour but to have
a meet but a great example of what hard
work can do in this country and career
and technical said you know education is
our one size fit up represented some
career in technical centers and HBCUs
and and and and you know educate our
young people for generations to come is
so important to us and that's why we're
here because long after all of us have
gone what we talk about here today
and beyond today will affect those that
come behind us and that's my heart from
being here so when those that come
behind us will benefit from what we do
today and we are about outcomes in this
administration and results for Halle
Berry because that's our team in the
United States of America so mr.
president thank you thank you enough a
dream I really is disagree on the
officer did thanks for doing a great job
really doing a great job
so man called me and he said you got
open to churches
got overtime and he's somebody I respect
a lot and I watched him defending me a
long time ago long before I even did
this and he was so tough he was so
brutal the last thing I thought he was
was a pastor he was a pastor and he's a
great pastor and he's loved in his
community and I'd like to ask my friend
pastor Daryl Scott to say a few words
you are terrific
Thank You mr. president listen we are
attempting to navigate we are when I say
we I'm speaking of you as our leader in
this administration we're attempting to
navigate our way through uncharted
waters right now we are
that has been it's unprecedented in
modern history and so you know we're
learning more about this challenge every
day information is being updated every
day but information is also being
updated every day things we thought
three months ago we don't think today so
we're navigating our way through this
and we have to all be on one Accord in
this I thank you mr. president for your
bold leadership I really believe that
the effects of this pandemic would have
been much more severe if it had not been
for the measures that you enacted and
that this administration has enacted in
conjunction with the state governments
to try to contain and curtail the spread
as much as possible this president has
pledged to give assistance to
underserved communities that are
impacted by this hope it 19 by Perseus
pledged to give us assistance in those
areas which will actually coincide with
the president's already existing
initiatives in the urban communities
throughout this country this is
assistance that he provides regarding
this call the 19 body which will be
another layer it will add another layer
to the president's already existing
urban revitalization efforts this person
is providing ppb loans that are focused
in and on minority in urban and and
underserved and disadvantaged in
distressed communities news already
stated how you're providing
unprecedented funding but HBCUs he's
provided billions but entities that are
staples in the black community child
care centers and so they can remain open
during this time you're also providing
underserved communities with testing and
healthcare resources so that know that
no one has reached or no one is denying
access to vital equipment and final
testing you've committed to discovery
and addressing the reasons why some
communities particularly the black
community seems
affected more so than others and you're
making sure that the federal government
is also going to cover health costs for
those that are under uninsured or
underinsured we thank you for this our
country has been placed on pause the
pause does not stop
we've been on a pause but we're about
the present go and get back going again
I said it before unashamedly and I say
it again this president has been I've
lived under 12 presidential
administrations I was born during
Eisenhower's administration this
president has been the most Pro black
president in my lifetime but when I say
bro I'm saying it grow in the sense of
being proactive
he's been Co active rather than reactive
to issues concerning minority
underserved and disadvantaged
communities than any other president in
my lifetime I really believe history is
going to be kind of to you mr. president
then fate news media is that it can't be
any worse thank you you tried to
initiate action to restrict travel from
other countries and you know we're
seeing that you were a visionary in that
area and I know you're doing your very
best I know you have the heart of this
country in you are and I know you're
doing your very best to preserve this
great Union as far as I'm concerned
myself my business partner green Lanier
the company that we have we appraised a
billion dollars in liquidity to help
provide PPP loans to businesses that are
in need of in conjunction with the cares
Act and I thank you that you've directed
the White House opportunity and
revitalization Council who couldn't
think of anyone more capable than dr.
Carson and Scott Turner here to engage
with the focus on
that I've been in fact impacted by this
and there they are
they have been interacting with the
number of coalition's they're doing a
great job
so we thank you and mr. president we
have the back thank you I do so god
bless you thank you very much yeah now
I'm going to be making a tour of the
factory with the head of Ford and some
other people and I'd love you all to
join me if you could would anyone like
to say anything yes please
I'm dr. Rajiv angry I am a nurse and I'm
also the chief executive officer of
Detroit Medical Center yes so when we
talk about the impact of kovat 19 I
lived it I stopped it and we went
through it together from the beginning
of the pandemic we've always had a focus
of making sure that our patients are
cared for and our staff were cared for
and so we began a rapid testing and
talking about partnership we weren't
able to do this with Wayne State
University and by the way just as a note
off my script we do have medical
students from Mary so we've done many
things were partnered with the city
we've partnered with the state state and
I think many of the steps you've taken
Hancock has gotten us to the point where
I'm proud to say that we're starting to
see a decline in the state of Michigan I
will pause here though mr. president to
say thank you I am filled with pride and
actually come
by the fact that the President of the
United States has taken time out of his
day just to stop and listen to what I
have to say Jory thank you thank you
very much so where health care is
concerned since I am representing the
healthcare organizations where we're now
at the point and dr. Carson certainly
alluded to some of the chronic
underlying issues that the black
community faces and so we're at the
point now in or journey where we're
encouraging people to return to
hospitals return to the emergency rooms
because we want to make sure that their
product the chronic issues are addressed
I would be remiss if I did not cause to
say thank you to the incredible
frontline workers that have just given
heart soul muscle and sweats to make
this a possibility even for us not just
at the Detroit Medical Center but
throughout our city the strength and
their commitment and their dedication
has been humbling and also being started
and I believe about my heart that
they're the reason along with all our
community members have taken on the
spikes that we're winning this battle so
some of the highlights and I'm jarem and
I have talked with certainiy works
through strategies thank you
one of the things to his point is that
the pandemic has certainly just brought
to light some of the disparities that
have already existed and he will say
that I'm honored to be appointed or
space from the virus task force and
through that the task force is really
gonna dress
some of the inequities and figure out in
the long run what do we need to do
differently and so we we help to
continue this fight mr. president as you
know hospitals were significantly
impacted for inability to do any kind of
some of course scheduled work that has
certainly impacted us so I do want to
pause though and say thank you we have
received incredible support from your
administration and not just not just the
portable things and so I actually that's
the letter for you signed by myself I
can the Michigan Hospital Association
just to not only thank you but to ask to
continue the work that you're already
doing which is the relief efforts across
the country for healthcare organization
and so we look forward to continue to
work with you but I want to add just my
personal experience hood as a nurse or
mom and a hospital administrator I'm
home it was a weekend afternoon and my
phone rang and I picked it up and
someone said this is Rear Admiral John P
you won't get my last name but this is
who I am I'm calling on behalf of the
administration dr. Gregory what do you
need my job is to help you to get what
you need it was a great relationship not
just for me but for the hospitals in
Detroit and I think the moment that
wowed me because I'm so big on
follow-through is that a few days later
the rear had world called me and said
dr. Gregory did you get one and so there
is my script and then there is my
personal story of engagement and
to get us there so the hospital
community on their behalf I want to
thank the state and federal government
for Swift financial support the federal
government Wow what all that you've
distributed so far we thank you this has
helped our hospitals to remove these
states somewhat liquid but there's a lot
more work to do and I want to thank Ford
who has worked with us symbol for PPE
have been from Ford and then thank you
for signing legislation to support
healthcare facilities now the ongoing
support for Detroit is vital in Michigan
hospitals need help to continue to
ensure financial viability but I just
wanted to pause to say thank you for
being with us in this thank you very
much very nice I appreciate that very
much
Alfonso if you could and I guess we're
gonna be a little bit late we have the
head of Ford waiting for us right now
I'm going to walk through the plan so
we'll go perhaps quickly and I think we
have Robin going to speak too right
so what do we go quickly and we'll take
a couple of questions or the fake this
and then we're going to the pledge
president thank you think this is honor
to be here it's an honor to be invited
out as a developer working with several
communities in the state of Michigan I
believe that our Tunes own has been a
great opportunity jaronda staffers team
has done a great job we appreciate you
having the foresight to put them on
here thank you in fact they're doing
such a great job I received call asking
for mr. Smith's address they think
they're going to go to his office and
talk to him because he's raised to the
big power so as developer talk about
several mayor's that welcome you in
Winnie County they say you're more than
welcome to come to the cities you want
for the vice president I would just like
to say thank you and the opportunity
zone and what it brings to the
communities is very good and we have
some projects has actually shovel ready
now that the pan in because it still is
slowing and it's allowing us to get back
to our daily routine and we're looking
for getting Shelton Brown thank you very
much thanks so fun so I appreciate it
are you doing really well too that's
great Robin hello mr. president how are
you such an honor thank you my office so
much I want to first tell you thank you
so much I have a cold it's a 19th father
and I got diagnosed probably about a
month and a half ago as positive and
just sitting at home and you know
watching TV and heard you talk about
hide report and talk to my doctor we
took it and within five days I'm here to
say I'm so a lot of people have said
that yes and so I want to first I go off
it tomorrow I think I really took the
question yes exposed to a couple of
people and I said let's do a shot the
doctor said he recommends it but I
looked at the story of Karen and many
others and I said I said what do we have
to lose
what I said anyway so you had a good
experience I had excellent experience a
lot of people do yeah it was dumb you
know I hadn't I'm a bronchitis be
staffed by credits as a child and so to
have that breathing interaction going on
again from I'm telling my age from about
30 or 40 years later it's just like whoa
but so long so to be able to get that
particular description and be able to
take in and to gable to breathe again
and within hours was just amazing so and
I'm not blood cottage if you had the
bronchitis problem you're a prime target
of this invisible enemy right yeah I
actually I thought that I grew out of it
you know how they say you grow out of
things and so I haven't had an actual
episode since I was 13 years old
right so to have one when I'm now 50
will tell about is this like okay Wow
where'd it come from
so then it was it was quite a little
scary thing but I must admit it's like I
said up to now man how Bad's it again I
don't have to really calm myself down
and kind of go through it I owe it to
disease itself was it they roughed out
night sweats the whole nine yard
coffin a little weird coffee cup isn't
the same as a normal clock come on we're
in a type of coffee but yeah I left it a
whole gamut but thank God I was able to
stay at home and I did recover and you
hear a lot of different stories
especially with Karen I met Karen a
couple of times I know I found something
from doing you know opportunities on
development things like that in real
estate but that was something that was a
little bit scary so I do actually just
from watching you want to be in here you
talk about it I was able to call my
doctor and say listen gang this right is
the you know this must be was going
and then I need to get tested on top of
it so at that time we had to have
prescriptions to get tested and so he
brought the script we got it done and I
was positive and we've got the project
for Flint actually fought a cocktail
because the Thoroughbred Center and the
zinc and like I said I took it at 8:30
9:00 o'clock 9:30 that morning 9:30 in
the morning by 4:00 or 5:00 o'clock I
was breathing good so many people with
that experience they just don't want to
write about it please do bad so I first
want to thank many many people thank you
for that information because information
is key and when you're in real estate
you realize more information that you
know the more things you can get done
and I am very thankful and like I said
we're working in our opportunities also
we thank you for that in Detroit our
property values and everything in
Detroiters will be up we have a lot of
heavy players that are doing a lot of
things in bills to bring those property
values back up for our residents and
that's amazing so alright thank you a
lot
thank you squared sir thank you very
much appreciate it
do you have any questions real fast
thoughts and any questions for anybody
in the room John we've heard from a
number of people over the last few weeks
mr. president is the numbers of starting
again the number of deaths is starting
to down Hospital capacity is increased
to say that the goal of mitigation
to ensure that the hospitals did not
become overwhelmed we appeared for the
most part to be at that point so why not
just reopen the country on a more rapid
basis the me on that what are your
thoughts but we want them to reopen John
the numbers are going down very
substantially without question I mean
very powerfully going down you look at
Florida you look at Georgia you look at
many of the states the numbers are going
down and they've been open and for very
substantially open and pretty much
completely open in some cases and we
want them to reopen I mean literally I
just got off the phone with CDC and they
talked about churches I said I want the
churches to open and the people want the
churches to open and I think you'll have
something come down very soon from CDC
we want to get our churches back it's
our country's coming back we did the
right thing make it agree I think we
would have had you know well over a
million could have been a million and a
half to two and a half but he had people
dead and so we did the right thing it's
it would have been a horrible it can you
imagine if you so what we have now and
multiply that times 15 or 20 times so we
did the right thing but we now want to
get going but we also learned a lot
about the disease during this time
nobody knew we learned about the
tremendous contagion and the problems we
learned a lot a lot of very important
facts but now it's time for our country
to open again and I think you'll start
with churches I think you'll start with
some other states that have been very
resistant you have a lot of
unfortunately in this case Democrat
governors I think they think it's good
politics to keep it close or what are
they doing they're hurting themselves I
don't think it is good politics they're
hurting themselves they're hurting this
state and it's not good so I think you
can see pretty much people are gonna I
think that being forced to open frankly
the people want to get out you'll break
the country if you don't
and I think they look at it as a
possible November question it's not a
type of course it happens to be very bad
for them so you don't see that happening
I think Jenna I think that your third
quarter is going to be that transition
quarter we're almost there and it's
going to be the transition quarter and
it's going to be really good but the
fourth board is going to be big and next
year is going to be a big year for this
country how close are we to in your
words breaking the country unless we
start the reopening process more and
more quick well I think we're very close
to opening up the rest I think there's a
lot of pressure put on certain
governor's that should be further along
they should be further along than they
are and they really they should not be
doing what they're doing so we'll see
what happens that but I think the
country is going to be in a very good
place very good place and we have a lot
of ammunition left you know what that
means
is that a lot of ammunition left in the
country in terms of the Fed the Treasury
and all the people that are working
under we have a lot of ammunition left
unlimited ammunition if we need it but
we won't need it thank you are you
prioritizing the reopening of churches
over other establishments no never a lot
of the church history they're so
important in terms of the psyche of our
country beyond W to me they use the word
essential anything churches are
essential so important people want to be
in their churches it's wonderful to sit
home and watch something on a laptop but
it can never be the same as being in a
church of being with your friends and
they want to have it opened and I think
that's going to be happening very
shortly very very shortly so that'll be
put out maybe tomorrow maybe today
yesterday a tweet that you might
withdraw funding from Michigan later in
the afternoon you seem to say that
wasn't
Fairey if that threat still on the table
sir I didn't say it wasn't necessary I
said that I might have to do that yeah
we're not going to go to voting by mail
voting by mail is wrought with fraud and
abuse and people don't get their ballots
that happened to be in a certain
district whether it's Republican or
Democrat thousands of ballots are sent
out but they don't happen to get it some
people are calling with my mouth they
call it a panic where is it where is it
the elections coming and all of a sudden
the election comes it goes and they say
hey I've never got a ballot but wow that
didn't affect but it did affect because
thousands of people that happens to you
go in your vote and ideally you vote
with voter ID and then you really have
an election but this country you know
you go out and you buy things and you
have your picture on the the you want to
vote the most important thing you can do
is vote and they don't want to go voter
ID so ideally that would be the idea
there are many places that have that
many places down but no I don't we don't
want to have vote by mail we want people
to vote now if you're President of the
United States and if you vote in Florida
and you can't be there you should be
able to send in a ballot if you're not
well you're feeling terrible you're sick
you have a reasonable excuse just a
reasonable excuse you should be able to
vote by by mail in you vote by mail it
but when they sent in the case of Nevada
where they want to send out thousands
and thousands of ballots and then
they're going to send it back who knows
whose side the ballot there's anybody
standing there acknowledging oh that was
mr. Smith that was a pastor Daryl Scott
that was Scott Turner that was John
James and great John James who better
win because you would be missing
something was she going to be a no vote
for this guy but
you know who says who who are these
people that are voting they get it it
comes by bail maybe maybe it doesn't
come a lot of the problem is in that
chip into certain areas you know if you
have an old Democrat area and now I have
to tell you the abuse tended to be on a
certain side rather than another side we
will get into that and frankly and the
Republicans want a very big event on
Tuesday where we have a man named Mike
Garcia as a congressman in a Democrat
area was not expected to happen and he
won by a lot of votes you know about
that John it was a big was a big
decision I was an incredible victory the
first time in 22 years 22 something's
happened but that was a vote by ma'am
they bailed it in and actually the
Democrats so they were losing and all of
a sudden they threw voter booths up in
certain Democrat areas I wouldn't say
that was so good right but it didn't
have any it didn't have a bunch of an
impact so Mike Garcia won and we wanted
Wisconsin but we can't we can't do that
to vote to really vote and without fraud
you have to go and you have to vote at
the polling place people have to check
you in but a general can you just
clarify for what federal funding you're
considering removing from Michigan oh
I'm not going to discuss that there are
so many forms of funding and we're not
going to discuss that what we want is we
want good straight honest voting okay
honest voting and by the way if that
could be honest which obviously it can't
be you get a ballot you're sitting in
your bedroom signing it who knows who's
signing it who knows that it never gets
you ask who knows that they don't pirate
him you know they they pirate these
applications they print new voting forms
and then they send them around people
sign them or one person signs it with
different pens and a different signature
every time it's it's obviously there's
going to be fraud we're not babies
this tremendous fraud you have all of
the harvesting you have all of the
the things they walk in at the end of a
race we had a lot of them in California
they walked in bed at the end of the
race and they dumped thousands you think
the race is over you think somebody
wanted that all of a sudden out of blue
come thousands of votes at the very end
Oh what happened harvesting wonderful
they harvesting they just happened to
find thousands of ballots just at the
end so somebody that thought he or she
was going to win the race all of a
sudden gets clipped we can't have that
John go ahead mr. president in the midst
of this coronavirus crisis the Chinese
government is considering a new national
security law that would give it the
authority to clamp down to a greater
degree on Hong Kong do you have a
message for the Chinese government about
changing your relationship with Hong
Kong well we'll have to see what happens
I haven't seen it yet I'm getting a
little briefing but I'll have a
statement to make at the appropriate
time pom-poms been through a lot mr.
president we've seen this historic
flooding we've seen this historic
flooding and you're in Michigan and we
have seen forecasts that we could see a
really severe hurricane season as FEMA
and the federal government prepared to
meet the needs of some of these
potential disasters
you say FEMA and the federal government
yeah they here right now FEMA's here
right now they did a fantastic job on
the coronavirus a fantastic job in
Michigan they did a fantastic job
everywhere frankly you know I bet the
letters you can see them now because
this is one of the plants where we make
thousands of ventilators but FEMA was
involved that we also have said have you
know you know you know that the Army
Corps of Engineers at the highest level
is right now at Michigan work you know
the fact that you had some dams breaking
that shouldn't have broken and they were
probably maybe not maintained properly
something happened to could have been
human error from what I understand but
it was certainly a physical error - they
were old but you have the best in the
world to fix them and to get that water
stopped and we have fever here and we
have the Army Corps of Engineers here
they'll be able to take care of it let's
go take a tour and you're all invited to
join me if you want and we'll take a
look at a great assembly line making
ventilators thank you think